[Music]
you may have spent your whole life
questioning certain things around you to
no avail whether it's how something is
made or why your body reacts in a
certain way these questions can burn a
hole in your mind if left unanswered if
you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and enjoy today we
are giving you the answers to ten
baffling questions you have always
wondered about why orange juice tastes
bad after brushing your teeth if you've
ever brushed your teeth and tried to
drink a glass of orange juice within
five minutes of doing so you may have
experienced something unpleasant the
orange juice probably tasted disgusting
and there is a scientific reason why the
foaming agent used in most toothpaste
sodium lauryl sulfate weakens the sweet
taste receptors in your mouth it also
heightens the taste of bitterness in
anything you eat the combination causes
the orange juice to taste less sweet and
more bitter thus making it difficult to
swallow why hair turns gray by the time
you hit the age of 30 you may start
noticing that your hair is not the same
lustrous hue you have grown used to and
though this is something that happens to
almost everyone the cause isn't exactly
known scientists believe that the melon
in producing cells melanocytes which are
responsible for hair color start to slow
down production which causes the hair to
gray then eventually the melanocytes
stops functioning altogether which
causes hair to turn completely white
what okay
is short for it's one of the most common
words in the English language and you
probably have already used it once today
but what exactly does okay mean the
abbreviation actually has origins that
date back all the way to 1839 when
abbreviating words was all the rage and
one of the major abbreviations to cross
over to modern times is okay which back
in the 19th century was the abbreviation
for all correct why cats love boxes cat
sitting in boxes are so common that they
sparked the famous if I bits ice it's
meme the movement but what is the deal
with cats loving boxes research has
suggested that cats love boxes because
it is a safe place for them their stress
levels and anxiety lower when they have
access to small enclosures like boxes it
also helps because cats are
known to hide when they are confronted
with things they find unpleasant and
boxes are the perfect hiding spot for
the fraidy-cats why the sky is blue you
may have been asking yourself or your
parents this phonetic question since you
were a child and even if your parents
didn't have the answer then science can
explain why the sky is blue now it all
comes down to blue having a smaller
color wavelength than the rest of the
colors in the rainbow our atmosphere is
made up of molecules that cause the
sun's rays to scatter into different
colors and since blue has a smaller
wavelength it's easier to distribute
therefore it's scattered more can you
rip off your mattress tag you may have
noticed when buying a mattress you are
gifted with the threat of going to jail
if you rip up the mattress tag but is it
that big of a deal if you remove the
unsightly tag the answer is quite simple
if you own the mattress you are free to
remove the tag but if you are a
manufacturer or distributor of the
mattress it is illegal the tags became
mandatory for manufacturers to show
consumers that the mattress wasn't
filled with undesirable stuffing like
newspaper or food waste why flies can
never find the window if you ever left a
window to your house open you've
probably dealt with an annoying fly
getting in and then you had to deal with
the fact that they can never seem to
find their way out this is because flies
are attracted to the carbon dioxide your
body gives off and any desirable smells
they can use that scent as a target but
when they want to leave they have no
target to leave them out instead the fly
relies on light to help them exit what
usually ends up being a shot in the dark
when windows are involved what the
numbers under a barcode mean in the u.s.
virtually every product sold to
consumers has a barcode barcodes were
introduced in the 1970s to help quicken
the checkout processes but why are there
numbers underneath the barcode the first
six digits are the manufacturers ID
number the next five digits are the item
number and the final numbers help the
computer know the product was scanned
correctly why there is a crescent at the
bottom of your nail have you ever looked
at your nails and wondered why there is
a lighter colored Crescent at the bottom
of your nail bed
these little Halfmoon looking nail
features are called liudmila and they
can be singles to what is going on in
your body if you have missing Lingala
you may be suffering from iron
deficiency if you have large lunula you
may have thyroid or blood pressure
issues why your fingers wrinkle and
water
chances are you have taken a bath or two
in your lifetime which means you may
have noticed that your hands and feet
turn into prunes while underwater this
is because when you are in water your
blood vessels right underneath the skin
restrict as an involuntary nervous
system reaction the reaction causes the
upper layers of your skin to prune and
wrinkle people with nervous system
damage actually don't experience
wrinkled fingers and toes when they are
submerged did we answer any questions
that you have always wondered about
react in the comments section below and
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things
[Music]